we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail came in it's a voicemail from
a i don't know that i would call it a
very angry trumpet or a very angry right
winger but it is certainly someone who
believes we are wrong about everything
and they know everything that's a really
important element of this voicemail
let's take a listen to it remember you
can call anytime and leave a voicemail
two one nine two david p is the
voicemail number let's listen together
yeah videos and man i just couldn't tell
you how wrong like an alternate universe
hypocrisy at every corner and you guys
just don't see it
i'd love to point it out for you i mean
i could if you ever had a conservative
on your show we do often live debate you
I mean you just be humbled how might you
and the fake news never really you know
has anybody on this is crazy I mean
you're transgender athletes video I mean
you're saying we use that issue know the
reason why we talk about it is because
we cannot believe our eyes to not
believe what's happening is this real
life or the twilight zone
you guys you're unbelievable yeah what
they're referring to there is I got a
call I I think it was during a live
stream last week or the week before
where I was asked about this issue of
transgender athletes and participating
and this that the other which you know
should transgender individuals
participate based on their biological
sex or whatever and I said that I I
don't disagree that those are real
questions but that that is not the
primary issue around trans rights and
that when we're talking about issues of
trans rights and bathroom policy and all
of this difference of you know job
employment discrimination that bringing
up questions about if you're born
biologically male should you be allowed
to weight-lift against other women if
you are a trans woman later in your life
I'm not saying it's not a question I'm
not saying
needs to be figured out but it is not
the forefront of the issue around trans
rights and a lot of people were angry
they said David how dare you say that
that issue of men's and women's sports
leagues is not the foremost issue of
trans rights well it's not now as far as
you want to debate me call in we take
calls every week on the broadcast show I
accept calls typically at least once a
week during an impromptu livestream on
either YouTube or twitch I am glad for
you to call in and tell me all the ways
in which you were right and I am wrong
on the bonus show today the Donald Trump
campaign has revoked media credentials
for Bloomberg News reporters over a
decision not to investigate 20/20
Democrats in a very particular way that
Trump wanted them to do we will also
talk about Elon Musk of Tesla Fame
testifying in his own defense
during this defamation trial over the
pedo guy tweet if you don't remember
that we'll catch you up on it it is
interesting what is going on and we will
also discuss on the bonus show the first
Supreme Court gun rights battle in 10
years which may have a significant
impact on the legal landscape so a lot
of really important substantive good
stories about freedom of the press about
the Supreme Court gun safety regulations
and so much more on the bonus show get
instant access one of two ways become a
member at join pakman.com it takes under
a minute become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show also takes under
a minute probably under 20 seconds if
you already have a patreon account
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show and that's where I will next speak
to you or otherwise we'll be back with a
new show tomorrow including coverage of
today's Trump impeachment inquiry
hearings in the House Judiciary
Committee